my name is
Katerina Budka I am an activist of the automaidan movement I will tell you what
it is what we do what we did
during the maidan
but in the car what we did during the
maidan was to go to the president of our
former Yanukovych we went to the Minister of Internal Affairs
and other officials we took them out for
the line of comfort,
respectively, if they could
ignore the dough on the maidan, then
when people come to your home it is
much more difficult days after this
automaidan movement arose in many
cities, it even appeared in Europe, the
largest automaidan action with the
largest number of participants, it was a
trip, I lived 29  December,
then, according to various estimates, there were from 2 to 4
thousand cars that took
part in the action; it really was
a
lot.  country
which  they are coming now they are coming from below, that is, there is already a need for changes the need to fight corruption the changes in our country are the best that we really lived like Vivaldi the traffic police have changed in most cities in Kyiv now there are no traffic police officers there are police really this change is better because they recruited new people and now you can really communicate with them, you can find a common language with her, but so far this change is only for the police on the roads, that is, it is only a patrol police